you
well the message of a good boss bad boss
if I was to summarize it in a few
sentences that that if you think about
what it takes to make a great boss
there's lots of things they do but
there's a thread that runs through it
which is that the best bosses find ways
to be in tune with the people they lead
so they understand what it feels like to
work for them which is sort of almost
like a trite and obvious comment but
where it gets more interesting is
there's actually a large body of social
psychological research that shows that
the more power you give people the more
oblivious they become to the people they
lead so in many ways the most effective
leaders find ways to overcome this sort
of obliviousness and and the other part
about it which is quite interesting is
there's a lot of research that shows
that when you put people in positions of
power they're watched very very closely
by the people they lead and apparently
this is related to how were wired is not
just human beings but as Apes there's
some cool research that shows that in
the baboon troops that the alpha male is
stared at by members of the troop every
20 to 30 seconds and and so that's if
you will the thread that runs through
the book that is that the best bosses
find ways to be in tune with their
people and then they try to accomplish
two goals the first goal is performance
or their competence and the second one
is humanity or to enhance people's
dignity but this idea of being in tune
is the key idea in the book
what would I that's a great question
what would I like to see happen with the
book well I mean there's a couple of
things I would like to see happen
probably more than anything else I would
like to see it influenced or at least
affect a conversation in organizations
about what a great boss is because one
of the main things that I'm inspired the
book is my last book which was the no
rule and I was deluged with
comments both conversation and literally
thousands of emails and one of the main
characters and all of those emails are
actually 80% I counted them several
thousand emails was the boss either it
was somebody who had a bad boss and
didn't want the boss to be a jerk often
or was somebody who was a boss and
wanted to not be a jerk but the thing
that also came out of that was was the
notion that people they weren't just
concerned about civility or being
treated kindly they actually wanted to
either be a competent boss or work for a
competent boss so so sort of the short
story is is what comes out of that is
hopefully the way that organizations
will define and breed bosses are people
who to go back to the key sort of
definition of a good boss versus a bad
boss people who are both competent drive
performance and are civilized and viewed
by the people who work for them is
treating them with dignity and to me if
you only get one of those two outcomes
you are in some ways a failure as a boss
but it's not an easy thing to do because
it is a balancing act
well probably what inspired it and I
I've already referred to this in some
ways was that when I wrote the no
rule I was daily with the they
lose with these emails many of which
were actually about bosses that was the
primary theme but another thing I think
that influenced me in writing the book
was that I realized in in the various
organizations I was studying and the
ones that I was working with was whether
or not I was talking to the CEO of a
large company or a first-line supervisor
or like a good friend of mine is
actually a cop he works at in Hillsboro
and and he's a captain and he also heads
the sniper unit of the local SWAT team
so he's like a boss but who whoever I
was I was talking with the notion that
there were bosses who had immediate
charges that they had to deal with in
one way or another
no the sort of relationships I think are
really important in organizational life
and although there's a whole bunch of
other issues like strategy and how you
structure the organization which I do
touch on some to me that the key part
that was interesting was this
relationship between the boss and the
immediate sort of human relationships so
they have other people they work with
and lead most directly are something
that as I said I can talk about it with
Nick I can talk about it with a
first-line supervisor and recently I've
been doing some work with groups of CEOs
and the whole thing they talk about is
their team and all the problems of
keeping their team together and in fact
if you look at some recent research on
firm performance it turns out that one
of the primary ways the CEO has an
effect on firm performance is through
the team that he or she puts together
and manages directly because they they
can't run around and do everything
they've kind of got to delegate to their
immediate team so so to me it was simply
something that was important from both a
performance standpoint and the emotional
and physical well-being of people in all
sorts of jobs
so so the the question of how this book
relates to my earlier book the no
rule well as I already mentioned
that it relates in the notion that
there's lots of there was a lot of
response about bosses and from bosses
but it also relates in that there's a
chapter called on boss holes so I stole
that from the Urban Dictionary the term
boss hole and and the point of that
chapter is first of all that there's a
whole bunch of things about being a boss
putting people in a position of
authority over somebody else it's one of
the most reliable ways to turn somebody
into a jerk that you can imagine because
first of all there's power poisoning I
already mentioned this you start
becoming oblivious to the people you're
leading there's the time pressure that
comes with it because usually have more
time pressure you're you're held
accountable for performance and you're
blamed very often when things go wrong
whether or not it's your fault
and then often being a boss these days
was a lot of sleep deprivation in
exhaustion those are great ways to turn
people into jerks and so one of the
things that I emphasize and I thought
about more in this case where I was
focusing on bosses is that this notion
that I'm bosses need to be civilized and
you should be in tune with their people
that there's something about the job
they have that they have to fight a
whole bunch of tendencies that are going
to lead them in the opposite direction
which is to be insensitive selfish and
probably incompetent in some ways so so
I think that that's another another
thing that sort of sort of came from it
and you know when I look at the stories
of what I'm bosses do to their employees
it is absolutely unbelievable there was
there was actually a consulting firm
somewhere in the Midwest where they had
a company picnic and they wanted to
motivate people to to sell more because
they weren't selling enough and they
essentially waterboarded somebody at a
picnic to Minh it's one of those things
that you just can't believe that it
happened but it's just one of those sort
of weird things in the bus actually sort
of a nice but very aggressive guy and
and and and he was so the boss was
dumped in the water down the guy's
throat and he was saying he was saying
see how hard he's struggling this is how
hard you should be struggling for sales
and so there's something about the
position and this was a pretty nice guy
that sort of leads people to do sort of
idiotic and cruel things at times so
that's I guess that would be some of the
links back to the to the no role
and then and then the other link since I
for better or worse I've been condemned
to be a research professor much of my
life is that as with this book and my
prior books with Jeff Pfeffer - I try to
make an evidence-based case for
everything I do so there's lots of
stories like the the waterboarding story
story is in there but the basis of
everything comes from a series of peer
review studies so that tends to be what
I draw on
yeah so this sort of interesting I so
what the way that I think that the good
companies are addressing the concerns
raised in the book and in one of the
perspectives in the book which also has
been emphasized by Gallup researchers is
that although the CEOs and senior
executives and companies tend to get a
huge amount of the credit or the blame
if you look at what probably matters
more for performance it's sort of the
average quality of leadership or
management in the organization
that really matters not whether or not
the CEO or even the top team tend to be
great and so the way that I think that
some of the best firms so I thinking of
General Electric Procter and Gamble and
there's also some amazing Asian firms
that are starting to really have an
impact I've been working with the
Singapore government lately they really
get this and it's the notion that to be
a great organization they've got to have
a not one but a bunch of great leaders
who are if you will
confident and treat their people with
dignity and respect
and so so I think that is a competitive
advantage and there's pretty good
evidence about this that that that firms
have and it's not just the focus on the
CEOs and that's always entertaining to
talk about CEOs because we love to blame
them or make and occasionally worship
them although we seem to be in a period
of mud throwing rather than worshipping
but but but still it's sort of the
people who do in many ways the more
ordinary less flashy things that keep
organizations going and determine that
the difference between the best and the
worst and in fact since we're at
Stanford one of our most distinguished
and smartest and most charming emeritus
professors is James March who by some
accounts came fairly close to winning
the Nobel Prize last time and one of the
things Jim March has been saying for a
long time is that simple competence and
organization is one of the most
important and underrated things it's not
very exciting but it's one of the things
that really distinguishes the difference
between you know good great mediocre and
lousy firms so so I guess this is part
of that call for sort of simple
competence
the book is coming out in about a month
so I'm just now sort of getting some of
the reactions in reviews and the like
which are generally positive but where
I've really sort of felt their response
are when I talk to groups of executives
and other managers about the ideas in
the book and there's two sorts of
responses and I was think it's important
to emphasize negative responses as well
as positive responses even though we're
always selling books in that some people
will sometimes say well this is obvious
I knew this already but I think that's
also a point of the book and actually a
lot of work I've done with Jeff Pfeffer
too is that the best leaders and best
bosses are often Masters of the obvious
and and where I think that it does have
a positive effect in fact I'm thinking
of a of a group of CEOs that I did a
workshop with so this was this was a
group of 15 CEOs of large local
technology companies and the reason I
think that session worked was they all
became quite introspective about their
management style and how it felt like to
work for them and things that they could
do to become more in tune with the
people they they led and they and they
talked quite openly about mistakes they
made so what they make decisions where
they'd run over people they wouldn't
talk to them they wouldn't understand
how upsetting a small decision was one
of them actually described simply the
the concept of sort of like taking away
the donuts in the morning he couldn't
believe how upset people got to save
money I mean just little things like
that and and then also talking about
times when they thought they've done a
good job of getting other people's
perspective by listening to them by
engaging in constructive conflict with
them so so so to me I think when the
book is useful it creates some
introspection and some conversation
about how I can number one be more in
tune with the people I lead in number
two find ways to be both if you will
more competent and more benevolent or as
I described in the book to enhance
performance and also the human dignity
that people they lead so so I think
that's when it works and and not
everything works every time but I'm
having some success with that